there's a really funny video of
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham from
1999 which has sort of been revived and
it tells us exactly why Donald Trump
could well be impeached in 2019 now it's
really important to understand the
context and that what I'm going to play
for you is not to make an argument for
or against the impeachment of President
Donald Trump it's to tell you that the
arguments that Republicans are making
today even Republicans like Lindsey
Graham were ridiculously laughable back
in 1999 when it was Bill Clinton that
they were talking about impeaching the
the term underlying crime is been used a
lot lately and the idea of underlying
crime is that if Donald Trump didn't
commit any underlying crime in this case
it would be personal collusion with
Russia that you can't impeach or indict
him for coverup related actions or
so-called secondary crimes like trying
to obstruct the investigation into
whether or not he colluded with Russia
and Trump has been continuing to parrot
this on Twitter I mean it's really
getting a lot of oxygen Trump tweeting
quote only high crimes and misdemeanors
can lead to impeachment there were no
crimes by me no collusion no obstruction
by the way no obstruction that doesn't
appear to be true so you can't impeach
it was the Democrats that committed the
crimes not your Republican president
tables are finally turning on the
witch-hunt so it turns out that
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham
actually has something very important to
say about this why do we care what
Lindsey Graham says well we care what
Lindsey Graham says because he's become
one of the most sort of sick of Fanta
crown nosing unhinged defenders of
Donald Trump and anyone that Donald
Trump has determined is a good guy at
this point in time throwing any bad
argument has been doing Lindsey Graham
time and again to see if it sticks but
Lindsey Graham actually laid out in
really simple and clear terms that it
actually doesn't matter if there was no
underlying crime committed by the
president and Lindsey Graham actually
goes further in the clip I'm going to
play for you Lindsey Graham argued in
1999 when it was about Bill Clinton that
it doesn't matter if there was any crime
at all
if the president behaved in a way that
smears the United States that requires
the healing of the country after gross
acts by the president even with no crime
being committed or at least any
indictment whatsoever it would still be
justified to impeach a president here's
what Lindsey Graham said just apply it
to today instead of to Bill Clinton
which is what Lindsey Graham was doing
in this clip so the point I'm trying to
make is you don't even have to be
convicted of a crime to lose your job in
this constitutional republic if this
body determines that your conduct as a
public official is clearly out of bounds
in your role because impeachment is not
about punishment impeachment is about
cleansing the office impeachment is
about restoring honor in integrity to
the office so this is why even though I
don't believe there's the political will
to impeach Donald Trump at this point in
time because you need some Republicans
in order to do it I don't believe that
there is even really the time to carry
out the removal of Trump via impeachment
even if proceedings started today I
believe it's still faster to just vote
in November of 2020 and remove the guy
from a sort of practical perspective I
do believe that the impeachment debate
would be absolutely logical to actually
have in earnest in the House of
Representatives start a house debate
about impeachment to determine whether
the circumstances justify starting
impeachment proceedings in the house
which of course eventually get to the
Senate needing to vote to decide what
they believe should be done that makes
sense and Lindsey Graham in this video
which I just played for you makes it
clear that impeachment is not about
punishment
I mean I'm quoting one of the biggest
Trump defenders a Republican here
impeachment is not about punishment
impeachment is about cleansing the
office as Lindsey Graham said
there couldn't possibly be a term that
better applies to the White House under
Donald Trump and to the people around
him than a need to cleanse the office so
it's Lindsey Graham himself who made the
case very succinctly and very
articulately 20 years ago he wanted it
to apply only to Democratic President
Bill Clinton but it actually applies
perfectly to President Donald Trump in
2019 support those who support the David
Pakman show and today that includes our
good friends over at BRD Bitcoin wallet
these guys are awesome and the BRD
Bitcoin wallet is absolutely perfect for
anybody who's getting into Bitcoin or
cryptocurrency for the first time
because it was designed with simplicity
and ease of use in mind but you'll also
love it if you have experience with
Bitcoin it's an all-in-one app for iOS
and Android that lets you buy Bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies using your
credit card lets you store everything on
the app for free you can trade and sell
cryptocurrency within the app and when
you use BRD wallet you're the only
person who has access to your Bitcoin
BRD doesn't store any of your personal
information you don't even have nor do
you need a username and password on the
platform it's all within an environment
that's virtually impossible to hack so
your cryptocurrency is safe extremely
easy to use
it's how I store my own Bitcoin I think
you'll be impressed with it too it's the
first-ever Bitcoin wallet in the iOS App
Store and now they have over 2 million
users for more than 170 countries be our
DS mission is to make buying selling and
storing Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies simpler more efficient
and more secure and they've done an
awesome job check out my interview with
Aaron from the BRD team we had a really
interesting discussion about the state
of cryptocurrency going forward you can
also download the BRD app for iOS and
Android I've put a link right underneath
this video